so uh i am i am phil lua i am the
community engagement
manager for omixologic africa engagement
as a whole
and i have a practicing
molecular biologist and
and geneticist i am a post graduate
of bioinformatics in the institute of
of psychology and genetics in novosible
russia so lovely to actually i was here
so um uh going straight to the talk
going straight to the talk um
i would love to start by saying that
despite the poor capacity development
for genomics research in africa and the
effort of to empower african scientists
get involved in genomic research
particularly
those research that involve uh african
populations
uh we we had consortium coming up the
likes of human hereditary and health in
africa the history
africa
consortium that we had other initiated
initiatives that actually came up
such that we could have databases uncle
i would love to
to throw out some
some some some questions in a bit
here in africa before the year 2010
by informatics and genomics
training where it was likely done by
small groups at very few institutions
and they heavily relied on visiting
expats in
in europe and america and some of our
our african experts had had to go to
europe and america to
to to get this experience firsthand
however we have seen
we we have actually seen how the effort
to change this
this this as i mean has actually
searched so so far we saw the african
society of human genomics rising up
through the human registry and held
uh consortium in africa we saw them also
coming up in 2011.
jared was
empowering the africa
that is i mean that that actually have
the bioinformatics education the african
researchers that that that are properly
trained and the african researchers that
could actually engage proper informatics
research in in africa so um
fast forward to today we also understand
that individuals that do not have access
to formal graduate trainings at this big
big universities like we used to know
um
we we understand that there are actually
some challenges that
that the present day
researchers actually experience so i
would love to call on on uh on dr
francis dr francis i love to ask from
you
uh so far so good i i remember that
recently
you had a training in
bioinformatics in your country and uh
you tried as much as possible and in
your institution you tried as much as
possible to
to work i mean to work towards towards
bioinformatics training can you just
share with us the challenges that you
actually met during this training and
then and what were actually the
constraint what was the success you were
able to have
so thank you thank you mr alaba tutu
thank you all to all the panelists and
it's a very great pleasure to be
among you this evening
and to discuss about the challenges of
bioinformatics in africa
and thank you also for introducing that
great um
workshop that we recently organized in
january 2022
at about the news center of the
university of the only one
and talking about the challenges and
even the success
of
that training
i'll start by saying that
talking about bioinformatics in africa
there is no more
no more a challenging talk
it's no more a
it's frequent aspects because it's
something that people are getting
involved and involved
and the interest has been also increased
as you just include introduced from your
initial speech
and regarding that special training
it was a little bit striking because it
was a first kind of such training to be
organized in our institution
and we even went too far by training
people on ngs
which is
a very very new aspect in the research
domain in cameroon
so definitely
having people of a very good background
to get involved in research training was
a very great challenge
you have people from different
background people who have never
worked on molecular biology and we want
to get involved into bioinformatics you
have biologists you have engineers you
have you have you have
but definitely the first challenge was
to get them
to bring them together
how to try to have people with the same
background
in order to assess them that at least we
moved together during the training
and
this was achieved
this was achieved because we mainly
focus on those who at least has a good
background in molecular biology even if
they
are going to work on bioinformatics and
they don't yet have bioinformatics
background
at least we are certain that they can
have a valuable background in molecular
biology knowing that if they are
acquainted with biological data it will
be easy to talk with them about those
data and how to handle those those data
and we finally
got something very interesting from
those that we selected because the final
number of participants selected for that
workshop was 20
and i can say that yes yes
the workshop was not to bring them or to
build them as as part of bioinformatics
but the workshop was just to get them
acquainted with the introductory
knowledge of bioinformatics and i think
the goal was set
but as soon as you run a search training
and as soon as you introduce people to a
new discipline
you should are certain that they
continue building that skill
to be able to have this the final
required skill that you plan
before you are training
and that's why during that workshop we
bring in pan bio or omega and omega
logics to be sure that after immediately
after the training those participants
will have other platform other learning
platforms other windows where they will
be able to continue getting much
training about bioinformatics so
definitely it was a very good experience
and
we really we really really need
such experience again we need such
training again in africa and empire
cameron in particular to get other
involved or to introduce further into
the discipline of bioinformatics
yeah thank you so much for francis
that was so but also detailed because
uh you you with the i mean you a
uh
from the from your first and experience
looking i mean experiencing experiencing
bioinformatics training even as a
trainer and
in cameroon was actually
a a great tax for you
so um
i i really really appreciate those those
inputs i would love to call on someone
in the field before i call on rissi yeah
so that she can share i experience at
kenya babuan experience with us how how
how she got involved involved in
bioinformatics and how she was able to
cross over but before i call on reese
i'd love to call on
dr
seaney barry dr shawna barry are you
there
yes i'm here
okay so uh the the the quick question i
would love to ask it's still kind of
still related with this question is
um
what do you think is actually
uh the obstacle that is actually
preventing
the the public health sector for example
in west africa using nigeria as an
example what do you think is actually
entering them from i mean from from
really engaging molecular research and
molecular diagnosis uh
that would actually uh bring into use
the expertise of bioinformatics
knowledge
yes like you said i'm a clinician i'm a
medical microbiologist and i i want to
look at you know
discussing with all mixed logic you know
about health research you know uh and
diagnostics and in treatment
so and um i i re i just recently got
introduced to omex logic about three to
six months back and i've been following
and like i
i want you to know that in my country in
nigeria we're actually into molecular
you know research a lot of centers now
have molecular laboratories but we are
very like you said we are at the team at
the very baby face
of a bioinformatics a lot of a lot of
centers have not killed into
bioinformatics
and then
like
my center is service oriented it be that
as it made i also enjoys no research in
diseases and diagnostics we wouldn't
don't mind but a lot of hindrances a lot
of encumbrances are there in my country
right now you know that most of our
training institutions most of our
education institutions are home they
have been on strike for the past several
months
and it's only those institutions that
are not public that are running and then
because of the challenges which is
global you know the economic meltdown
everything going into researches
especially molecular training molecular
research is seriously challenging
although it is not on daunting it's not
something that cannot be summated
and that i believe that like the first
speaker from cabarro said africa is in
the eating face africa is lenny and i'm
sure that nigeria will also catch up
weekly because i as i've been following
the presentations this morning i've been
hearing people from russia states you
know the show state university i've been
hearing other people who have logged on
to the omixlogic platform and already
doing well are catching up i had the
first speaker talking about what they do
they understand and then the training
that they've been giving people even
spreading far back as cameron spreading
back to neighboring nations in nigeria
so i know i i can i can see a future for
nigeria with comics logics and
bioinformatics so that's that's what i
have to say for now
okay thank you so much thank you so much
uh we can
actually draw draw a summary that
um
that even if the government is isn't
actually helping to push this to work
uh people are still engaging
the knowledge which is actually a very
very good one so i'm going to call
on risky at this point to to actually
share with all so received from a
first-hand experience
uh
i understand that you you you actually
had some some
entire intra african
education
what
is actually the gap between i mean in
molecular studies for informatics
studies um
between kenya
and zimbabwe and uh and what has the
experience been so far for you
okay uh
thank you so much for the opportunity
so
my introduction to the field of
bioinformatics actually started in kenya
my background is in biochemistry and
molecular biology so i had my internship
at the kenya medical research institute
and at that point my boss at the time
had some projects that required a bit of
genomics and bioinformatics knowledge
and
by virtue of that he organized a lot of
knowledge transfer seminars whereby you
would have people coming to teachers
different things
so back then i wasn't confident enough
that i understood by informatica such
because when you said bi-informatics um
you'd have to be in places like erie
where they offer a bioinformatics-based
internship or you would have to be in
the enbit program because it's one of
the major programs that offers brain
informatics training in africa
and um
with these few centers it means that you
needed to know someone with knowledge
in terms of bioinformatics or who knows
a sort of training a sort of institute
that is offering that kind of training
for you to be able to be exposed to this
kind of knowledge
then
transitioning into my masters i'm
currently doing my master's in genomics
and precision medicine at the african
institute of biomedical science and
technology in zimbabwe so apes as an
institute they have a bioinformatics and
genomics cohort and they are also part
of one of the nodes for the h3 bionic
program
so transitioning from kenya to abyss um
despite my program being genomics i you
cannot afford to
like ignore bioinformatics because
i think where we are going in the life
science field uh knowledge in
bioinformatics is very very crucial so
past part of my uh course here at apes
is in bioinformatics i had to do a
module in bioinformatics so that was
like in class sessions and then
in addition to that we also had to take
up some other online classes in
futureland um
where they do like bioinformatics
training for biologists because you need
to match both
into one and then being a note for h3a
bionic um
we i am actually a beneficiary of most
of the trainings at h3o bionic
and
it has been a continuous process because
uh the more you learn the more you're
curious you want to know more um and
that's how i ended up at the omics logic
research symposium uh like i've been
attending a lot of bioinformatics
research in bosnia because i want to be
familiar with the kind of research that
is currently going on
and
through this the gap has been that
there's no systematic training in that
uh you need to start with this part and
move to this part so it just happens
that
in your journey as a student when
there's need for bi-informatics training
that is when it it comes up
but i don't really think it should be an
excuse because
with getting knowledge from bits of
beats i
came to grill up to a position whereby
currently
by attending what you call codeathons
whereby you meet and you're grouped into
different kind of groups then you get to
run a
one such uh program is by the african
society for bioinformatics and
computational biology
so i joined it last year in october i
was a participant then but then based on
how they were running things i i decided
to pitch a project which i'm currently
leading it's called the gn basics blog
project whereby we're trying to explore
the feasibility of using genomic skills
bioinformatics and newborn screening so
i would say that it it is
a really an appeal tax for a student in
africa but you still need to understand
like what is driving you and
be able to connect with the right people
who
know the right resources that you need
to continue building your career because
most of this knowledge is in informal
setting unless you actually enroll as a
bi-informatics student full-time
you shouldn't like limit yourself to say
that since i'm not training in
bioinformatics i don't want to get that
kind of knowledge so that is the gap i
would say stay
in brief
yeah thank you so much thank you so much
i
i actually love those submissions that
you actually brought because they are
actually actual for a lot of persons
um
and how actual are they
uh
for
for some some persons they actually
they're looking hard at having a
systematic way of
of
of learning but it wouldn't it would may
not actually come to them like that so
other persons actually
need to do bioinformatics at a
particular time of research and they
have to catch up with the reality of
what bioinformatics is and you know
the accessibility of trainers
and and and and so on with things that
you subtly mentioned over there
and um
and that will actually take me to the
next to the next
to the next question
i i hope to call on
mr dick only after i throw this question
to to a lecturer that is over a year and
the question is today majority of
bioinformatics teaching
is at postgraduate level and student
tends to enroll in these programs from
different backgrounds
and terms of about training received i
mean in terms of
receipt
and this training both the lecturers and
the students they actually have to face
their own challenge of catching up with
the know-how so the question is
um
dr francis the question is to you
what do you think is the biggest
challenge of owning bioinformatics
skills
for
for trainers
and uh for students and those
in the field
and those and those that are actually
working yeah so that's the question
okay thank you mr vitte tutu
for the question
uh that's a very very tricky question
because
the problem is there
and i think we all know the problem we
all know the problem you know
bioinformatics is practical
bioinformatic is practical
and most of the time those getting
involved into bioinformatics have never
practiced
bioinformatics
and i said initially they are from
various background
they don't know what
is decoding
they don't know what is programming
they finish with their undergraduate
level they reach the graduate and the
postdoc graduate level and
they generate data and they want to
analyze the data
so definitely definitely
bringing together those individuals from
various background
into the same discipline which is
bioinformatics
is
or is it very very difficult
as a lecturer imagine that
i start teaching bioinformatics at the
postgraduate level
means that someone who started
is undergraduate in biology
in biochemistry
in mathematics
has never joined
those skills together
to make the discipline of bioinformatics
as he restarted or he will start
at the postgraduate level
so for you or for me as a lecturer
is already a great great challenge
and this brings in the question of of
what or how is our national education
policy been established
because a new discipline like a
bioinformatics to get involved
this policy
how to develop global guidelines
to establish
new bioinformatics degree program at
different institutions
for us to asserting that those getting
involved into the bioinformatics
disciplines
for the practical
session or at the practical level which
is generally the postgraduate when they
generated
their own data
they already have a very good background
to get involved into the discipline and
to master easily what they will be tough
i will take an example of one of my
lecturer from kenya um
from erie he told me that he started
decoding at the age of 10
he started decoding at the age of 10
and me when i started with
in forget it i started getting involved
in bioinformatics i was already 30
and i want to master
the skill he is using to analyze his the
biological data that i generated during
my
phd imagine the difficulty imagine the
challenge
the guy was just playing with the court
the guy was just playing with the
programs and when you are looking at him
it's like he's coming from a new planet
a different planet which unfortunately
is not really really really really easy
to
go to to accept but definitely it's a
real situation it's a true situation
because
of that
system
which
unfortunately
did not allow us to start or to grow up
by getting familiar with those basic
background
and bioinformatics today is something
that
as a biologist
you can't move without it
if you are dealing with
biological data
if you are generating data
you need
bioinformatics to analyze those data
so
at this step i think
we just need
to bring it our government to bring it
our
policy
to interpret them for them to understand
the needs of this new field
of study
to allow those
interested to start at the basic
background level to get familiar with
the discipline
in order to become the good spine
information that we need as trainer of
the new generation
because today i started in biochemistry
i continue with molecular biology and
i'm getting familiar with bioinformatics
definitely definitely
my background or my skills
my experience will never be the same
as
the one of my instructor who started at
the age of 10.
so this is one of the aspects that i
think we should have we have to bring in
and that has to be considered
by our
our policy
yeah thank you so much for for that uh
submission it's actually very very
actual
yeah because our realities in africa
isn't the same realities with uh
with with other places
and now that you mentioned about about
one of your instructors that started
coding at the age of nine
i remembered working in an academic year
i had to go join some
some basic python class
over a year
even though i was a teacher in that
academy i had to go to join join
secondary school i mean
uh
from from seven from eight students
learned some of those coding and i
actually didn't experience it a lot
until i was already my post graduate so
that's actually a bridge that's actually
a bridge yeah so i will be between a
similar question
yeah now even maybe uh maybe i facing
before removing another challenge is
a neat thought of cheating
you know
most of us get involved into
bioinformatics
during workshops
or maybe during short-term internship
and most of the time those functions of
my internship have been carrying out
abroad
and we do it for a very short period of
time and when we come back
the facilities we are getting there
are no more available in our
institutions
and definitely
definitely this also impacts
our training experience
and also our long-term training capacity
so definitely
this is also something that has to be
addressed
if i'm getting trained
how long
what sustainable measure is putting in
place to ask certain that
as soon as i'm starting
my training will get continued till i
acquire
the best experience that i need
so thank you
okay yeah yeah thank you so much for
that yeah because it's actually there's
power in continuity like
like um
like
like like receive actually shared so i
would be drawing almost the same
question to receive
but uh i will be put putting it in a
in
in a different way because doctor just
said that there is a systematic way of
teaching about informatics so let me ask
you uh receive have you recently joined
uh i mean
joined um
a training program and you you are
actually stuck in the process of
training uh what part of bioinformatics
training seems seems hard
hard for you yeah
uh okay thank you so much for that
question
so indeed a majority of the trainings
that i have joined i usually the basic
introductory level
but then
when i started working on this
particular project uh
the genomics screening um i i tried to
join different training that now you
know you've been learning these skill
sets but you need to apply them
so at the application phase is when you
actually realize oh
so they used to say we call for variants
but i can't actually call for variance
like how do i go about it so
you usually get stuck when it's now time
to actually apply the skill sets that
you have gotten so the training might be
nice um
structured well structured you are
following it but if you don't have
actual data to actually apply the skills
that you have learned then it becomes a
problem
so uh what you're trying to say is that
okay
sometimes we have we have the right
access to these things
but uh we still need some
hands-on practicals
that uh
i mean that we can do by ourselves so
that's actually the application phase of
the training so for the application
phase of
the training many times people get stuck
i'm not just about the coding now but
what what about uh
they already have access to the database
i mean
to the database and to the data as they
actually need
at the same time
um it's it's actually getting stuck i
mean they actually get they actually get
get stuck uh in the process
wow wow this is actually true and real
and and i i know some questions are
actually boiling in the minds of some
some persons i want you to start to
write your questions down so that uh so
that we can start to to answer it before
we round up this this this session i
would love to call on
on
on doctor
uh
on our consultant doctor to ask
him um
hello dr shawnee barry are you there
yes i'm here
okay uh lovely to still have you here
with us um
uh the question i want to ask from you
is uh to understand
what is actually the bottleneck really
affecting
uh
professionals
in the field
from accessing
uh bioinformatics knowledge from your
own from from your own perspective what
do you think is actually the bottleneck
that is that
that actually affects professionals
maybe genetic counselors maybe um
uh clinical um
uh
micro
biologist and co
and and these other professionals that
we have
on the field what do you think is
actually the bottleneck that's actually
stopping them from actually getting
access to
this information
thank you very much
the major challenge is in the curriculum
of training
you know everything is dynamic now
bioinformatics is coming i can tell you
that when we started training
there were no molecular techniques you
know in mexico and then gradually
molecular techniques came in and then we
were drafted into doing molecular you
know researches although this has been
far in other class
but it gradually got into our system and
a lot of us in our training got involved
in molecular techniques molecular
analysis of our you know our samples on
our molecular techniques in diagnostics
and things like that and then we
gradually get started imbibing it and
the molecular techniques
cropped into our practice a lot of our
practices now we use molecular
techniques in diagnostics and things
like that and so bioinformatics will
gradually get in when it gets integrated
into the training it needs set to the
next crop of professionals as a common
as they are trained if the young
government and the educational
institution gradually put putting
bioinformatics into our regular
institutions so that these things are
readily available and people get into it
as they as they are trained
so as the as the training comes up they
get into bioinformatics i get to know
that this is a useful tool in diagnostic
and research
and it gradually creep into our system
and clip into our practice i am looking
forward to a kind of cooperation among
researchers so that those of us who are
in the field who are clinicians we'll be
able to you know our diagnostics would
be best i would have people we can rely
on to talk to say okay you can make my
diagnosis better right now we do a lot
of molecular diagnosis we want to go
into bioinformatics too this is a the
new area of you know research and
diagnostics we want to collaborate we
want to join people to do this so the
bottom next is that for now
bioinformatics is relatively new in our
environment a lot of people have not
caught up with it by the time the
research decision started catching up
with it by the time the training
institutions started catching up with it
by returning postgraduate medical
colleges catch up with bioinformatics as
part of diagnostics a lot of doctors a
lot of professionals a lot of physicians
like me who are the research oriented
would go into that and a lot of the
research centers in nigeria would also
when we get into bioinformatics when
these things get into our training into
our curriculum into our practice with
graduates so what i'm looking forward to
as part of this uh uh workshop it's
called mix comics logic workshop is an
and a further introduction a further
furry entire institutions so that a lot
of us can you know
get introduced to this and get involved
in it
thank you so much for that and that's
actually very very
very very true
uh
in recent times i
acted about nigeria this year uh meeting
with
with
um heads of department and me just takes
older
uh stakeholders in the different
faculties and i was so surprised that
our informatics wasn't
on the syllabus
even for the common biomedical student
so it's actually something that is uh
that is actually uh very very important
that even the american schools the
medical
student their medical students will
actually start to engage in mathematics
okay so at this point i would love to
call on uh mr economist
hello mr nicole are you there
yes i'm here
okay so the quick question i would love
i would love to share with you is
uh you have actually in recent time you
have you have actually engaged training
training
individuals in the field of
bioinformatics and the question is uh
what do you think are actually the the
the challenge why
do i
um uh the trainers the students and the
lecturers
uh
what what do you think actually the the
entrance to these people opening up to
bioinformatics training in africa
because they need to actually open up to
it before they can actually
get the training so that's a question
sir
all right thank you for that question um
i would say that um like the speakers
that have spoken earlier on our state
there are a number of challenges when it
comes to
africa also catching up with the um the
speed of
brain
use in
umiq sciences generally but nonetheless
we have seen from africa that
particularly here in nigeria that more
people are getting interested in
learning these skills
all right um how be some of the
challenges we have noticed from our
works um you know in recent past um
ranges from
um
you know issue of an economic power to
be able to assess this um training to
assess these um i mean discourses these
programs um also to some of the
technical challenges that participants
have during these programs right um you
agree with me most of um
we condone
most of our
studies are programs
researches we do them online and we've
seen situations where participant begins
to complain about even
good internet
accessibility okay and these quite a
huge challenge
um equally most of these programs come
at a cost
and
because of the economic power also a
number of persons get to complain they
have the desires to join these programs
but then
they have no choice but to draw back at
some point
and that's why we've seen more more
people join our free webinars and maybe
workshops some of the workshops that are
sponsored
under the prime biotech scholarship all
right and then to get the follow-on
build up training because what we do
with umix logic is
um training building up the skills from
the very busiest okay so you see them
drop away from such full-on trainings
but of course i want to sincerely
acknowledge here
you know what mixed logic is doing um
here in africa particularly the support
of the pembroke international office to
ensure that um this the cost of these
trainings is
is made available with a lot of partial
scholarships and
the rest for participants from africa
all right
that's quite very very helpful
but nonetheless
these are some of the challenges we talk
about the technical aspects talking
about internet
i've seen people even on some of our
workshop programs complaining that the
internet is not strong enough not
necessarily that they are complaining
their internet is not strong enough but
you find them difficult having
difficulties and systems some of those
pipelines are
platforms i mean and you get to let them
know
that it's about their internet network
you have to change locations change
you know their source of connectivity
and we've seen that get and resolved and
then they move on then lastly that i'd
like to mention is um you know
bioinformatics also comes with um
you know
i wouldn't i wouldn't say beats me a
good knowledge of coding skills okay and
then we have seen that but because they
are getting introduced yes many of them
like directors mentioned earlier
while in school they were never
introduced even to molecular techniques
let alone bioinformatics okay and so why
going through these programs they're
getting to see new concepts and learn
new things and especially when we not
get to the coding aspect a lot of them
get lost and then get discouraged but
that is why also i want to acknowledge
what we are doing with the omis logic
platform the lane dot misleading
platform because particular can get to
uh i mean get introduced to
these new feats these new um concepts
starting from the bikes and molecules
the business and then they build on
dusky so with tenacity definitely we've
seen people move from that very basis
being in movies with bioinformatics and
moving on to become an expert and even
conducting their own research is now
currently in their research fellowship
so um these are plethora of challenges
we've been having but thankfully we are
trying to bridge this gap with our set
of programs and it is our hope that um
we can contribute to this until we have
uh most of our institutions partnering
with programs like us and or you know
review the curriculum to accommodate
these changes
so i think until we get to that
stage
keep making
the progress assets
maybe in bits and pieces
yeah thank you so much for for that
um thank you so much for that it has
actually been been very enlightening
from from this part because
um
bioinformatics
bioinformatics actually has and promises
a lot
and
this
this
section has actually opened our minds
and our eyes to actually see the
challenge i would love to give us all
the ability i mean just i mean a a
closing i mean a privilege to actually
share a closing remark
on
one thing you think
will fix bioinformatics training in
africa so just just uh just round up and
give us a closing sentence about one
thing you think we we fix bioinformatics
training in africa
so i would love to call on
on
on on
on racy
okay i think thank you so much for the
opportunity uh so from my part as a
student and having experienced uh
bioinformatics in africa i would say
we need to start as more
maybe reach them when they're young um
like go to don't just train um post
graduate at postgraduate level can we
try from high school level like keep
telling them there's this thing called
bioinformatics
keep introducing them to coding and
also
the way i have understood it is
you don't need to be in bioinformatics a
bioinformatician to learn bioinformatics
because even in the life science field
you'll have to apply by informatics so
if we encourage more people more
students like you don't need to be
really like it once they understand that
you don't really need to be a blind
information to get the bi-informatics
skills then i think more people will be
open to learning and then if you like it
then you can go on ahead and do it full
time so that would be my batting remarks
like
uh let's get them young and let's
encourage
them to think
thank you so much get them young
encourage them to keep learning they
just take it from primary school and
separate schools
yeah i love that i love that okay over
to you dr francis
yeah so i think um
one of the most important thing is
that in addition to current
bioinformatics training uh capacity
building environments
like the h3a bar nets like omix logics
like the erie
we need additional
[Music]
flexible sustainable and high quality
bioinformatic training environment
and i think that's filling this gap will
help us to ensure that the biology
biological detached
giraffe of sample generated in africa
will finally be analyzed only by african
bioinformaticians
wow
that's that's actually very very
powerful no one will actually care for
our africa like we do
so
we actually need to become the expert
that we need to be able to solve the
problem that we have thank you so much
for that that's so short and very very
very powerful okay
i would love to call on dr shauna barry
if he's still with us
uh
dr sean charlenbarry are you there
hello doctor sean barry are you there
okay so i will give the the final word
to to um
mr adekunle adele
uh just give us a closing sentence here
on how to
one with this
okay please um
can can you please repeat that
yeah so the question is yeah can you
give us a last advice or a last take
home to
so the solution
that
you think we need
in our bioinformatics training in africa
just a closing sentence
all right thank you very much um i think
personally we need to begin to engage
more and more the policy makers the
educational policy makers you know um
um indeed in this continent about
bioinformatics and the need to integrate
this into the curriculum um there is i i
want to believe so much that we can
actually scale the the accessibility and
the you know the the use of
bioinformatics in our educational space
with with that of course uh most of our
engagement personally as an as a group
as a team here have been much um within
the universities individually and um
it has been quite um a welcoming one so
but i think at this point with the
various programs out there history
boundaries and the rest of mixed logic
we might need to also begin to engage
policy makers and ministries of
education to let them see we need to
actually um take confirmation actively
into our
high institutions
that would be that from from my time
yeah thank you so much everyone for
joining us it has actually been a a
teachable moment for a lot of us because
a lot of patients have actually been
thinking how do i cross from this page
to this page how do i actually freeze
this this this challenge and how do i
become this
truth is that it is not new we actually
have to
to
to cross and jump over our own way uh to
build our own ladder our own way and
like we've heard from the patients on
the field that we buy informatics in our
medical schools we need it everywhere we
need it for the what about medicals and
for the sciences for every aspect of
what we do we need a curriculum that is
changing and we need you to actually be
the change you need to take it to the
schools and so on thanks so much
everyone for joining us i would love to
call on doctor conley for him to
continue because we have the
representative of prof on ground now